everybody and welcome to GameSpot's
unboxing of the newly announced amazon
fire TV I'm Sean McGinnis this is Danny
O'Dwyer right now Danny the fire TV is
not just a device for streaming house of
cards Haas it's not believe it or not
it's also part of Amazon's new gaming
initiative they started up their own
internal game development studio and if
they're actually releasing a brand-new
exclusive title for this device here my
god castle cards the video house of
cards the video game that may or may not
be it but we just got it today and we're
gonna unbox it so you want to do the on
that for sure so we've got the unit
there and the controller is coming up
next I'm going to de globos first of all
yeah so the device itself comes with the
streaming box and the control or end of
remote and that's ninety nine dollars
the controller is an additional forty
dollars ooh okay we've opened it here
here we go leave this is the that's it
the eunice it's pretty small you want to
unbox that one area or unwrapped it on
sheath ish feel like I'm opening up like
a fancy CD case I'm gonna remote-control
here pretty at pretty light on the
contents which I guess is kind of the
point of this yeah it's not taking up
too much room so here is the unit itself
the Amazon fire TV it's obviously a
pretty nondescript black square yeah
much like the Apple TV it's kind of
meant to just blend into your
entertainment system very small very
unobtrusive take a look at the ports on
the back to see what we got there's a
page we ports here alright so what do we
got we've got the power port we've got
HDMI optical audio we've got an Ethernet
cable for Wired odd for wired networking
it also supports Wi-Fi and of course a
USB plug in the back there and that's I
mean it's pretty much it it's a tiny
little tiny little idle device yeah it's
upset corners and yeah I guess the type
of people are gonna get this are
probably going to have a bunch of stuff
already so yeah yeah a nondescript is
possible via power brick here or it's
just you know simple into the wall
there's no there's no
brick attached to the power cord crystal
amazon logo on that as well yep so you
know something stolen your power cord
and there it goes here's the remote
control it again it's pretty you know in
obtrusive it has a play fast-forward
rewind and then oh and um um stuff and
then this kind of rebuild it also does
voice search so it's right little
microphone on there so you hold the
little voice button here and you say
search four types of car house of young
Joseph cards the video game I want to
play it I hear it's a good text color
component does not exist does not exist
so let's you've also got batteries Oh
comes with battery batteries comes in an
Amazon Amazon blue six branches what's
in the box all right what's in the box
so just for the sake of scale ok this is
what an apple TV looks like okay this is
a device that Apple has been shipping
for the past couple years it's pretty
comparable to the Amazon fire TV this
has much nicer specs to it but in terms
of like ecosystem it does a lot of the
same thing so there's apple TV amazon TV
this is a little bit wider but it's also
a little bit thinner so I mean they're
both pretty small and once you actually
put them under your TV next to your Xbox
or Playstation your yeah are you much
gonna forget they're even there back in
terms of objects which stream video
games yes videos and stuff here we just
compare the two of those there yeah got
it I think one of these things is not
like the other got this PlayStation 4 I
guess okay there we go but is that
everything's black and shiny isotonix
now is it still smaller I can't tell how
about this we you I don't think I'd does
much good have you got I'm not gonna fit
there we go there we go this is a very
helpful visual aid got the place over
here as well but I don't think God oh
this is our empty well now it's not this
is a real PlayStation tree I don't think
that does some of the okay
whatever old technology we didn't need
that ps3 anyways uh what about the
controller what about the controller
let's take a look at the controller all
right here we go so this is this is why
we're focusing on this here on gamespot
com because like we said this is part of
Amazon's gaming initiative they are
releasing games for this system their
own internally developed games as well
as third-party games like Minecraft and
there's like a whole list of gaming
companies on there as well you want to
read those off yeah Ubisoft I'm more
okay so the list is too and more I may
have over exaggerated that this more
Sega gameloft telltale boom oh yeah
walking dead is on here awesome 2k and
Amazon Game Studios I believe Kim Swift
just join them yes that's right and
Clint Hocking jewelry thing yeah okay
yeah they're hiring some pretty top
talent so you know here it is comes
wrapped in plastic also comes with free
batteries and this is the controller
itself immediate impressions is that
it's obviously styled after the xbox 360
pad with the offset analog sticks yes
although this these buttons here
definitely make it look like a non-live
controller I was about to say yeah you
remember that and also it without
sounding too mean it's a little bit
flimsy like a non-live controller J
little it feels a little light that
might change once you actually put the
batteries in there go for it um first
impressions it feel it does feel a
little a little little flimsy this is
heart oh oh yeah could you compare it to
a similar-looking controller I don't
know actually because it doesn't really
I mean it's hard to tell without the
batteries in there so let's run wait a
minute how do I have it you do the 361
they're the most yeah yeah well we have
an xbox one controller even better yeah
pop these in all right one hand in one
hand yeah where you going for wait so
about the same Emily it actually feels a
little bit better it's got a little bit
more heft to it with the batteries in
there and I would say are they are they
clicky at the back these ones are they
not
triggers not much motion on the back end
though no not not a whole lot of
actuation they're certainly not as much
as an xbox one controller it feels a lot
it kind of reminds me of the Wii U pro
controller rice so there's a great
cultural touchstone for you guys
certainly a lot more like the Wii U pro
controller than an xbox one controller
it feels a little I don't know I mean
these like controllers are hard to do
right like this is so good and the ps4
controller is so good because it took
console generations to iterate yeah on
initial ideas and even so it's what
you're used to so much of the time as
well yeah got at least a d-pad I'm not
as flat as how in fact here's something
really interesting if you look at these
start buttons on the xbox one controller
and the Amazon fire controller they both
have those three lines on their minds is
no standard yes the three lines has
apparently become like a standard symbol
for video game controllers start is dead
three lines is the future you know how
much to cost forty dollars yeah you know
what sure yeah fine I mean it's not bad
yeah it's not bad it all depends I
certainly it depends on the types of
games are gonna be available for the
system and whether it serves those games
well yeah um yeah feels feels fine I
don't know yeah I like it you like it
forty bucks and how much is this a
hundred dollars so the whole package
forty bucks I'll be able to watch
Netflix and play video games on my
television finally finally the one true
device that's gonna allow you to do that
all right there you go guys that's our
unboxing of the Amazon fire TV and the
controller as well make sure to stay
tuned for more coverage here on gamespot
com